mesdames c'est
monsieur ce matin en la basilique notre
dame de l'assomption à nice aux
alentours de 9 heures
trois de nos compatriotes ont été
assassinés à l'armé blanche dans des
circonstances abject en ces moments
tragiques
nos premières pensées vont à leur
famille à leurs proches mais aussi plus
largement à tous les catholiques qui ont
été frappés en plein coeur
à quelques jours de la fête de la
toussaint
je veux leur dire ici que la nation
partage leur douleur et leur immense
émotion cette attaque aussi lâche que
barbare en deuil
une nouvelle fois le pays tout entier
permettez moi de saluer devant vous
l'intervention immédiate de nos forces
de sécurité intérieure la police
nationale le raid et tout
particulièrement les policiers
municipaux de nice qui ont procédé à la
neutralisation très rapide du terroriste
le procureur national anti terroristes
et saisi la réponse du gouvernement sera
ferme implacable immédiate
j'ai d'ores et déjà décidé de porter le
plan vigipirate à son niveau le plus
élevé c'est-à-dire le niveau urgence
attentat sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
à ce titre la protection des bâtiments
publics des services publics et des
lieux de culte sera renforcée et la
mobilisation des forces de sécurité sera
accrue
le dispositif sentinelle sur décision du
président de la république va passer de
3000 à 7000 militaires
demain un conseil de défense a été
convoqué par le chef de l'état cette
attaque ignoble vient nous frapper alors
que nous sommes par ailleurs confronté à
une crise sanitaire sans précédent
la lutte contre le terrorisme nous la
menons de front avec la lutte contre
l'épidémie qui frappe elle aussi très
durement notre pays
le président de la république s'est
exprimé hier devant la nation pour
annoncer aux françaises et aux français
on sait les mesures décidées afin de
faire face à la violence de la deuxième
vague épidémique
il m'appartient désormais de vous en
préciser avec les ministres concernés
les modalités de fonctionnement et de
déploiement l'accélération de la
circulation du virus
vous la voyez sur l'écran frappe avec la
même brutalité toute l'europe
tout le monde avait intégré le risque
d'une deuxième vague mais personne
n'avait prévu une flambée si violente
est si rapide et d'ailleurs la plupart
des pays européens sont aussi conduit à
prendre comme nous des mesures de
restriction en france contrairement à la
première vague toutes nos régions et
toutes les catégories d'âge sont
touchées puisque le virus s'accélère
alors nous devons accélérer également
l'objectif est simple protéger la santé
de nos concitoyens en cassant par tous
moyens la spirale épidémique
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président de la république a décidé
d'imposer un confinement adapté à
l'échelle du pays entier à partir de ce
soir minuit et jusqu'au 1er décembre
je le dis clairement il n'y a pas
d'autre solution pour autant les
modalités et le contour de ce nouveau
confinement ne seront pas ceux de mars
car nous avons appris de la première
vague et nous en tirons les
enseignements
nous veillerons en particulier à mieux
préserver l'essentiel notre droit se
soigner travailler s'éduquer se former à
compter de ce soir minuit le confinement
sera décrétée sur l'ensemble du
territoire français
seule exception pour les départements et
territoires d'outre-mer
où le virus circule moins vite ce
dispositif ne sera appliqué qu'à la
martinique
des tests seront en revanche exigé au
départ ou à l'arrivée de ces territoires
afin d'éviter tout risque de diffusion
du virus
beaucoup des règles que vous avez connu
en mars et en avril seront reconduites
à partir de demain la première chose
c'est que vous ne pourrez quitter votre
domicile que pour cette certaine raison
est muni d'une attestation pour le
prouver
comme pendant le confinement vous
pourrez ainsi sortir pour faire vos
courses alimentaires pour vous rendre ou
revenir de votre lieu de travail et
exercez votre activité professionnelle
si vous n'êtes pas en capacité de le
faire en télétravail pour des motifs
médicaux vous rendre à l'hôpital chez un
professionnel de santé dans une
pharmacie pour des motifs familiaux
impérieux pour l'assistance aux
personnes vulnérables et précaires
notamment aux personnes en situation de
handicap pour une convocation judiciaire
ou administrative pour la participation
à des missions d'intérêt général sur
demande de l'autorité administrative
cela concerne par exemple les marottes
des associations de lutte contre la
pauvreté ou les distributions des aides
alimentaires à domicile pour un
déplacement d'une heure maximum pour
faire de l'activité physique pour
prendre l'air ou pour promener vos
animaux domestiques
ces déplacements ne pourront pas
dépasser ou se faire au delà d'un rayon
d'un kilomètre du domicile
je rappelle que pour les activités
physiques
seuls les pratiques individuelles et de
plein air comme le jogging s'oriente
autorisé dans ce cadre précis les salles
de sport et les gymnases seront fermées
et les sports collectifs de plein air
le foot le basket le rugby et c'est
interdit en revanche contrairement au
printemps les parcs jardins forêts
plages resteront ouverts comme je
l'indiquais tout à l'heure des
autorisations supplémentaires sont
prévus par rapport au confinement de
mars pour accompagner un enfant à
l'école où aller le chercher pour se
rendre dans un service public ou chez un
opérateur assurant une mission de
service public la caf l'assurance
maladie pour l'emploi les maisons
départementales pour les personnes
handicapées un rendez vous à la mairie
ou à la préfecture
je rappelle à ce titre que les guichets
de la poste et les guichets de banques
resteront également ouverts
vous pourrez allez vous formez
uniquement quand cela n'est pas possible
à distance vous présenter à un examen ou
un concours par exemple les examens du
permis de conduire et donc par
différence tous les autres déplacements
sont interdits ainsi il ne vous est pas
possible d'aller chez des amis ou de
recevoir de la famille à la maison dans
la journée comme le soir la semaine et
le week-end
il ne vous est a fortiori pas possible
de vous déplacer au delà d'un kilomètre
de chez vous en dehors des motifs prévus
il ne sera pas possible davantage de
voyager au sein du territoire national y
compris d'une résidence principale vers
une résidence secondaire
il y aura néanmoins une tolérance ce
week end pour le retour des vacances de
la toussaint pour chaque sortie
vous devrez vous munir d'une attestation
comme au printemps et vous trouverez dès
à présent sur le site du gouvernement et
sur l'application tous antique vide
cette attestation afin de faciliter la
vie quotidienne
votre vie quotidienne deux attestations
permanente pourront également être
délivrée
par votre employeur pour les
déplacements entre le domicile et le
travail par l'établissement scolaire de
vos enfants pour les déplacements
d'homicide écoles les fonctionnaires et
des indépendants pourront présenter leur
carte professionnelle ou tout autre
justificatif d'activité professionnelle
une amende forfaitaire de 135 euros sera
appliquée en cas de non-respect du
confinement et si vous ne pouvez pas
présenté de justificatifs
alors que vous êtes contrôlés en dehors
de votre domicile
enfin concernant nos frontières les
frontières intérieures à l'espace
européen demeureront ouvertes
en revanche les frontières extérieures
seront fermées sauf pour les
déplacements des ressortissants français
et des résidents en france sous couvert
de la pratique de tests toute personne
arrivant sur le territoire devra en
effet faire la preuve d'un test négatif
réalisé 72 heures à l'avancé
et pour ceux qui ne disposeraient pas du
résultat d'un test un test à l'arrivée
sera imposée comme au printemps
l'essentiel des établissements recevant
du public seront fermés les bars et les
restaurants les commerces autre que de
première nécessité d salle polyvalente
et salle de conférence les salles de
spectacle et les cinémas les salles de
sport les parcs d'attraction les salons
foires et expositions
là encore vous trouverez la liste
complète de ces établissements sur le
site du gouvernement
les dérogations qui avait été établi au
printemps seront maintenus les commerces
alimentaires essentiels les stations
service et les garages les laveries des
blanchisseries les magasins de journaux
et les tabacs les opticiens certains
magasins spécialisés l'équipement
informatique les télécommunications la
location de voitures et d'équipements
resteront ouverts par rapport au
confinement de mars tous les commerces
de gros les magasins et des jardineries
ainsi afin que pardon que les
professionnels puissent continuer de
s'approvisionner
les crèches et les établissements
scolaires jusqu'au lycée inclut les
établissements périscolaire l'ours
qu'ils assurent la garde d'enfants le
soir après l'école et les centres de
loisirs le mercredi
en revanche les établissements qui
proposent des activités extra scolaires
sportives ou artistiques comme les
conservatoires ou les clubs de sport
sont fermés les hôtels qui peuvent
garder une petite activité pour les
déplacements professionnels
indispensables mais les restaurants dans
ces hôtels seront fermés seul le room
service pouvant fonctionner tous les
services de transports en commun
resteront ouverts et leur niveau de
service devra être maintenue
j'ajoute quelques précisions l'ensemble
de ces établissements autorisés à ouvrir
devront appliquer les protocoles
sanitaires en vigueur notamment la mise
en place de jauge les commerces fermés
de même que les restaurants ne pourront
pas accueillir du public mais pourront
continuer de fonctionner pour les
activités de livraison et le retrait de
commandes tous les rassemblements sont
interdits sur la voie publique à
l'exception des manifestations
revendicatives déclaré auprès de la
préfecture
en ce qui concerne les lieux de culte
ils resteront ouverts en revanche les
cérémonies religieuses seront interdites
sauf pour les enterrements
dans la limite de 30 personnes et pour
les mariages
dans la limite de six personnes une
tolérance sera appliquée pour les
cérémonies prévues ce week end de la
toussaint ainsi que pour les
déplacements dans les 6 me
hier et les commerces de fleurs je vous
invite à vous rendre sur le site du
gouvernement pour retrouver la liste
exhaustive des établissements pouvoir
rester ouverts parce que nous avons
appris de la première vague ce
confinement sera adapté sur deux points
essentiels l'école et le travail en ce
qui concerne l'enseignement je les dis
les crèches les écoles les collèges et
les lycées resteront ouverts avec des
protocoles sanitaires renforcés
notamment le port du masque des six ans
afin de ne laisser aucun enfant sur le
bord du chemin tout en protégeant nos
enseignants je demande à jean michel
blanquer ministre chargé de l'éducation
nationale de vous apporter les
précisions nécessaires
merci monsieur le premier ministre le
président la république l'a annoncé hier
vous venez de le rappeler aujourd'hui
pendant le nouveau confinement les
écoles les collèges et les lycées
resteront ouverts nous avons nous le
savons tous à protéger l'éducation de
nos enfants tout particulièrement les
plus fragiles puisque nous l'avons vu
lors du premier confinement malgré
l'engagement de nos professeurs dans
l'enseignement à distance
nous savons que la fermeture des écoles
et des établissements entraîne
l'aggravation des retards scolaires et
nous ne voulons pas cela nous ne voulons
pas d'écart entre les élèves nous
voulons que les élèves puissent profiter
de l'école
l'épidémie ne saurait priver durablement
les enfants de tout lien avec l'école et
nous ne pouvons pas laisser la crise
sanitaire entraîné des retards qui sont
ensuite susceptibles de décrochage au
delà des conséquences éducative
nous savons aussi que le confinement
peut avoir pour les enfants des
conséquences sur leur développement
psychique sur leur développement
physique et même sur le sur leur santé
c'est d'ailleurs la société française de
pédiatrie qui le dit et que nous suivons
il faut dire aussi que très souvent les
contaminations qui peuvent exister se
passe en dehors de l'établissement
scolaire
autrement dit il faut bien se dire que
lorsque les enfants ne sont pas à
l'école ils ont des activités qui
souvent sont bien plus contaminantes
notamment dans le cercle privé
nous avons donc le devoir et ce devoir
être absolument fondamental de maintenir
ouverte notre école tant que nous le
pourrons
il y va de l'avenir de l'éducation de
l'avenir de notre jeunesse et donc de
l'avenir de notre pays pour les la
période actuelle nous savons déjà que
depuis la rentrée de septembre
l'application du protocole sanitaire a
abouti à ce qu'il y ait peu de
contamination en milieu scolaire je
rappelle les chiffres actuellement c'est
à dire au moment où les vacances ont
commencé il y avait 27 structures
scolaires fermés sur les 61 mille cinq
cents que compte le pays
c'est à dire 0 point 0 4% de fermeture
il y avait 2 193 classes fermées ce qui
correspond à 0 20 et 0 6%
le nombre de cas qu au vide sur les sept
derniers jours s'établissait à 8200 23
élèves
rappelons qu'il y à 12 millions 400
mille élèves dans notre pays donc 0 0 7%
et s'agissant des personnels nous avions
recensé sur les sept derniers jours
en 2060 trois cas pour un million deux
cent mille personnes soit 0 18%
je continuerai à actualiser ces chiffres
évidemment au cours des prochaines
semaines
d'autant plus que nous aurons une
politique de tests volontariste avec une
priorité pour les personnels éducatifs
de l'éducation nationale et des
collectivités locales pour être testés
sur le lieux scolaires ou non l'école
est donc en réalité un espace sécurisé
parce qu on y respecte plus les règles
sanitaires qu'ailleurs et nous
continuerons donc à fermer des
structures chaque fois que ce sera
nécessaire
sur la base des critères fixés par les
autorités sanitaires
et chaque fois que nous fermerons nous
appliquerons notre protocole de
continuité pédagogique que nous avons
déjà appliqué ces derniers temps avec la
possibilité d'un enseignement à distance
qui se déclenche immédiatement le
protocole sanitaire qui va s'appliquer
maintenant pour les écoles et les
établissements et donc durci comme l'a
dit le premier ministre son schéma de
base a été préparée depuis le mois de
juillet avec les autorités sanitaires
dans l'hypothèse d'un retour d'une
circulation très active du virus
il est transmis aujourd'hui à tous les
responsables de l'éducation nationale
locaux ce protocole permettra l'accueil
de tous les élèves sur l'ensemble du
temps scolaire il s'appuie sur les
dernières recommandations du haut
conseil à la santé publique
j'ai eu aujourd'hui même des échanges
avec les organisations syndicales mais
aussi avec les associations d'élus
les organisations syndicales m'ont fait
part d'un certain nombre de demandes que
j'essaierai de satisfaire au maximum je
pense en particulier aux personnels
vulnérables qui bien sûr n'ont pas à
venir danser semaine là en fonction
d'ailleurs d'une typologie établie par
le ministère de la fonction publique
cette typologie sera rendu public demain
avec les associations d'élus nous avons
pu avoir
là aussi un dialogue constructif elles
ont l'expérience de ces protocoles durci
puisque rappelons nous qu'au mois de mai
et juin et protocole était encore plus
dur si sur le plan notamment des
conditions d'hygiène et du nettoyage
très régulier des locaux conformément
donc aux derniers avis du haut conseil
le masque devient obligatoire pour tous
les élèves à partir du cours
préparatoire
le premier ministre l'a dit à l'instant
afin que ces élèves et leurs professeurs
se prémunissent au maximum de tout
risque de contagion hésiter éventuelles
même si nous savons que la contagiosité
des petits enfants vers les adultes et
semble-t-il faible j'invite donc tous
les parents à équiper leurs enfants mais
comme c'est déjà le cas au collège et au
lycée
des masques seront prévues dans les
écoles en cas d'oubli ou de difficultés
économiques d'une famille pour se
procurer de telles masses au niveau du
lycée une souplesse sera laissée aux
chefs d'établissement pour
l'organisation du protocole le protocole
de continuité pédagogique permet en
particulier d'envisager de
l'enseignement à distance pour les
élèves vulnérables ou pour des groupes
d'élèves
d'autre part la semaine prochaine les
écoles et les établissements
s'organiseront afin de limiter au
maximum le brassage entre les différents
niveaux d'élèves de manière très
concrète et bien sûr cela est précisé
dans les documents mais pour résumer il
ya quatre points principaux
l'arrivée le départ des élèves dans
l'établissement ils seront autant que
possible étalé dans le temps
cela dépend évidemment du nombre
d'élèves accueillis il y aura donc des
souplesses locales et là aussi un
travail entre l'éducation nationale et
les collectivités locales
la circulation des élèves dans le
bâtiment les déplacements des élèves
seront limités au maximum
ainsi dans le second degré une seule
salle sera attribué à chaque classe dans
la mesure du possible à l'exception des
salles spécialisées et des ateliers
en troisième lieu les récréations seront
organisées par groupes avec un respect
maximale des gestes barrières
lorsqu'elles sont trop difficiles à
organiser ainsi elles peuvent être
remplacés par des temps de pause en
classe enfin en quatrième lieu la
restauration scolaire est maintenue pour
des raisons sociales en particulier en
veillant à espacer chaque élève d'un
mètre autant que possible quand cette
distanciation pour être respecté les
élèves d'une même classe ou d'un même
niveau déjeuneront ensemble au même
endroit chaque jour et espaces et des
autres groupes
l'aération et la ventilation des classes
seront également renforcés comme la
désinfection des locaux et des matériels
le nettoyage des salles et des tables
sera réalisée tous les jours
celui des surfaces les plus fréquemment
touchés comme les poignées de portes
sera réalisé plusieurs fois par jour
c'est un protocole d'accord qui rappelle
ce que nous faisions en juin le lavage
des mains les gestes barrière le respect
de la distanciation physique quand elle
est possible feront l'objet d'une
vigilance accrue
l'ensemble des mesures sanitaires
s'appliqueront pour l'accueil
périscolaire des enfants dont le premier
ministre a parlé et c'est donc les mêmes
règles que l'on retrouvera dans
l'activité périscolaire
je voudrais pour conclure remercié les
professeurs remercier l'ensemble des
personnels de l'éducation nationale mais
aussi les personnels des collectivités
locales tout ce qui contribue au service
public de l'éducation nationale c'est
non seulement un effort mais un
engagement qui leur est demandé
cet effort ils ont su accomplir depuis
mois de septembre il l'avait accompli
pendant leur confinement et le
déconfinement ils ont droit à la
reconnaissance de la nation
je veux leur exprimer aujourd'hui parce
que ce qui se joue est essentiel pour
notre jeunesse nos enfants nos
adolescents comme l'a dit le président
de la république sont notre priorité
numéro un dans cette période de vie du
pays je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre pour les
universités et établissements
d'enseignement supérieur la règle sera
le distance yale dans les universités et
dans tous les établissements les cours
devront être assurées en ligne seuls les
travaux pratiques et enseignement
professionnel nécessitant du matériel
spécialisés pourront se poursuivre en
présentiel les examens et les concours
pourront se tenir avec un protocole
renforcé les restaurants universitaires
pourront continuer à fonctionner mais
uniquement pour des repas à emporter les
bibliothèques universitaires seront
ouvertes sur rendez-vous et dans le
respect d'une jauge les activités de
recherche doivent également se
poursuivre en télétravail
quand c'est possible mais également en
présentiel quand cela de l'est pas dans
le milieu professionnel
le principe que les activités se
poursuivent
toutes les entreprises qui ne sont pas
fermées administrativement doivent
pouvoir continuer à fonctionner le plus
normalement possible
je pense à toutes les activités de
service aux bureaux d'études à
l'industrie au btp aux activités
agricoles etc
il en sera évidemment de même pour tous
les professionnels du soin ceux du
service à la personne notamment de
l'aide à domicile ou de la garde
d'enfants il sera possible aussi pour
les professionnels de la culture et du
sport de continuer le travail
préparatoire au spectacle les
répétitions entraînement enregistrements
et tournage partout où cela sera
possible
le télétravail devrait être la règle
dans les conditions que la ministre du
travail vous présentera dans un instant
ainsi tous les fonctionnaires
travailleront en télétravail pour toutes
les activités qui le permettent en
présentiel pour le res s'agissant
notamment des activités de guichet je
pense ici bien sûr aux soignants aux
enseignants et aux forces de l'ordre
mais plus généralement à l'ensemble des
agents publics qui sont en première
ligne dans les services publics pour les
entreprises fermées ou qui rencontrent
des difficultés le recours au chômage
partiel sera maintenue dans les
conditions exceptionnelles qui prévalait
jusqu'à présent je laisse la parole à
elisabeth board pour vous préciser tous
ces différents éléments
merci monsieur premier ministre bonsoir
à toutes et à tous comme l'a dit le
premier ministre ce matin nous devons
tout faire pour éviter de connaître une
chute de l'activité économique aussi
brutale qu'au printemps dernier
ainsi tous ceux dont les activités ne
sont pas contraintes de fermer doivent
continuer à travailler
contrairement au printemps dernier nous
sommes mieux armés face à l'épidémie
tous les secteurs ont défini des
protocoles sanitaires très strictes qui
sont protecteurs pour la santé des
salariés
néanmoins dans la situation actuelle
nous devons encore réduire les
interactions sociales et les
déplacements
cela signifie que dans toutes les
entreprises les travailleurs que ce soit
des salariés comme des indépendants dont
les activités peuvent être exercés à
distance doivent télétravail et le
télétravail n'est pas une option
cette obligation sera inscrite dans la
nouvelle version